so carbon is an extraordinarily
important element the mass of carbon 12
is used as the standard for measuring
the weight of all the other atoms on the
periodic table so carbon it's around us
everywhere where all carbon there's lots
of carbon in us you know the
hydrocarbons within our body lots of
those lots are the structures inside us
and many many of the materials that we
use every day in fact a majority of us
used carbon in the form of fuels every
day to get to work or to go home it's
also of course the basis of all the life
the so called organic compounds which
make up you and me but also the element
carbon itself is quite exciting and it
exists in a number of forms for example
here this is so-called amorphous carbon
that's carbon that doesn't have any
particular form this is an element such
as you might use in the gas mask the gas
goes in here the poisonous materials
absorbed them clean air comes through
here so you can breathe in and out
through them so carbon is an extremely
common element but if it comes in a
number of different allotropes so
different forms and this one here this
is actually some charcoal which is just
simple carbons very very similar and
very very in fashion to graphite it's
also I think that carbon is the element
which has perhaps been the subject of
one of the most exciting developments
and the whole time I've been in the
chemist when Harry kroto
and his colleagues discovered so-called
buckminsterfullerene this molecule c60
that has the shape of a football which
nobody had imagined would exist and be
stable and now chemists all over the
world are using it and not only can you
get carbon arranged as footballs they
now realize that you can arrange them as
long them be long arranged as long tubes
so called nanotubes and you can even put
the c60 the football inside the nanotube
and one of my young colleagues here in
Nottingham is making what - called nano
pea pods where you put
these balls of c60 all the way along and
then the tube just like the peas in the
pod so carbon comes as graphite as
diamond and also as bucky balls or
fullerenes so the carbon here which is a
bit like the graphite is it's very
amorphous and it's very very
free-flowing so we're going to pour a
little bit of the carbon out onto the
papers of the you can see so you can see
it's a very light powder very dark
powder and you can see that it's a very
very nice easily maneuverable li easily
workable material very beautiful
material often used as a lubricant in
the form of graphite which is very very
soft in one limp dimension but also the
other allotrope of carbon which is
diamond is extremely hard one of the
hardest materials known to us very very
unreactive and perhaps it's why we give
it to our loved ones as engagement rings